- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to Ed talks on Khan Academy.
I know what you're thinking.
What are these Ed talks?
Well, this is kind of a subset
of the Homeroom with Sal conversations
that are more focused on education
or from experts or specialists
in the field of education.
We have a really exciting conversation,
but before we do that,
I'm gonna give you my
standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder
that we are not for profit.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khan academy.org/donate
and any donation amount makes
a huge, huge difference.
Also I wanna give a special
shout out to many corporations
who've really stepped up
and helped Khan Academy out
during the COVID crisis.
We were running a deficit
even before the crisis.
That deficit only grew as
our traffic to our site
went to about 250% of normal,
special thanks to Bank of America,
google.org, AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
Also wanna announce that there's a,
you can get a version of this
and the Homeroom with Sal
live streams in "Homeroom
with Sal," the podcast,
wherever you might find your podcasts.
So with that, I am excited to introduce
Elisa Villanueva Beard,
CEO of Teach For America.
Elisa, thanks for coming.
- Hey Sam, thanks for having me.
It's good to be here
and congratulations on all the work
that you all have been leading.
It's been inspiring to see
how you all have been meeting the moment
and so happy to be here
and in this discussion.
- And likewise and maybe a
good place to start with.
There's a ton of questions I wanna ask
and I wanna encourage everyone watching.
They can go on the message
boards on Facebook or YouTube,
wherever they're watching this.
And they can ask questions that hopefully
we'll be able to surface to Elisa,
but also just to get
everyone on the same page,
explain to everyone watching
what the focus of Teach For America is.
I think most people have heard of it.
It's one of the nonprofits
that I've always looked up to
when I started Khan Academy.
But tell me in your own words,
what is Teach For America?
- Well, our focus is working
alongside many partners to take
on educational inequity
at the highest level.
So what we know for sure
at Teach For America
is that potential is distributed equally
across all lines of difference,
but the opportunity and the access
to meet that potential does not
exist with all kids in all communities
in our country.
And long before COVID,
our system was not serving
many kids well enough.
And so I think that's
really important for folks
to understand.
And just to ground folks in that,
when you look at our
lowest income communities
who are disproportionally
children of color,
50% of kids are graduating
from high school
and that's compared to 96% of kids
in the most affluent communities
and have those kids
graduating from high school,
about 6% we get to and through college.
And Teach For America
exists to say that is not okay
and are committed to
creating a different reality.
And so we know that
the problem is systemic
and there needs to be change
within and outside of education
to really lead to a different reality.
We know many interventions
are needed in order to
be able to take this on.
And our contribution is leadership.
So we go out and we recruit
support and develop,
exceptional equity oriented leaders
who teach for at least two years
in urban and rural America.
They're expected to,
ensure that our kids get
the education they deserve.
And through that are able to
get this clarity of conviction
and understanding of the system,
the possibility of the
greatness of our children
and become lifelong advocates
and TJ jets in education.
We've been around for 30 years.
We're now 65,000 strong
core members and alumni
and our folks even 10 of our folks
in our alumni network
work within education,
or have a career serving
a low income community,
which is incredible because most folks
that joined us had no intention
of taking on this career.
- Just to give people a perspective,
when you go to an education circles,
people who are leading change
either directly, or even
now they work in industry,
but on the philanthropic
side or the policy side,
you meet, Teach For
America alumni everywhere.
So y'all have been definitely the alumni,
the leadership is happening.
And how does that happen?
You're recruiting students coming
primarily out of college
and graduate schools
with, for any young people listening,
either high school students
or college students,
how do they become part of
this Teach For America core?
- Yeah, our mandate is to go out and say,
get young people, 75% of our
core are right out of college.
And so we're just trying
to get people to see
this is amongst the greatest
injustices of our time.
There's no way for a country to thrive,
to be able to ensure that
everyone can fully contribute
without ensuring every child has access
to an excellent and equitable education.
And to take that on and
this young generation
really understands the nature
of the systemic problem.
We find that folks have on their mind,
the need to take on climate
change, income, inequality,
unemployment, systemic racism.
And there's many ways to take that on.
And one thing that we try to say is
ground zero for all these inequities
are honestly in the classroom
because you get to see how all the systems
in a community collide and end up,
'cause our kids don't live in vacuums
and all of that ends up in a classroom
and you start to see how you have to,
of course, hold our kids
to the highest expectations
and also provide all the supports,
all the unmet needs that
kids come with to school.
And then you're able to see
like things can be different.
Our kids can do anything
and we just have to be able to figure out
how do these systems interact together?
What can we do about them
and work in coalitions
and powerful coalitions
in common things done for kids.
And so we're out on college
campuses looking for exceptional
folks who demonstrate leadership and
are up for one of the greatest
leadership, challenges ever.
I will say, even as CEO,
my hardest job was right out of college,
which was being a TFA core member in 1998
in Phoenix, Arizona.
'Cause it's like the best
preparation to be a CEO,
I will say.
- I can only imagine.
Just fast forwarding to today,
especially with COVID I am curious,
we started talking before
we started going live,
but how has COVID
impacted Teach For America
in all directions?
What's going on with your
existing teacher core
who were in classroom,
but now I'm guessing doing
primarily distance learning,
how is that affecting your pipeline
of finding future leaders?
- Yeah, so we're in the moment,
as we all know the greatest
disruption in education
and in US history, recent
history, certainly.
And for us, we right away.
So I talked about, we have
this network of, 65,000 folks.
We right away knew that,
we centered on how we were
gonna meet the moment.
And so we're able to get our community,
our network, learning together.
We created an educator resource hub
to share best practices right away.
We had a platform where our core members
and alumni were able to,
put forth projects that
they were trying to fund
to just meet the basic needs for kids
or things that were most
pressing in our communities.
And so we're able to do that,
but for us very practically,
the first big pivot we had to make
was our summer training.
And so in March, when we realized that
we weren't going to be able
to run summer school programs,
which is a main component of
how we train our teachers,
we had to figure out if we were even gonna
be able to bring in a core,
because we were gonna have to train them
in a fundamental,
fundamentally different way.
And so when we went out
and asked our principals
and superintendents, do
you want our teachers,
even though they haven't, taught kids,
which is core to our model,
we got a resounding yes.
Now more than ever, we need your teachers.
And so we pulled together
just our incredible staff,
from national teams,
regional teams to design,
we have our Miami-Dade
executive director run
our program to design
a new training curriculum in nine weeks.
We executed on that and
four weeks and two days
and it was an incredible endeavor.
What we saw was our teachers,
coming together in one
network and feeling,
really the most prepared we've seen
in terms of what needs
we were able to meet.
We spent less money.
And so we were able to
pivot there and we saw,
our core members just
rising to the occasion,
the highest retention we've
had also throughout the summer.
So folks just so committed as we
process the world around us,
knowing, gosh, there's no greater impact
that one can be making them in
the classroom with students.
And so it's been quite
inspiring to sort of see
the staff and the network come
together to meet the moment.
- Yeah and there's something
powerful about that.
You like the entire education world
had to quickly go to virtual instruction,
which was probably
really good preparation.
There's a lot of negatives about it,
but really good preparation
for the teachers
having to then enter into a
virtual environment right now.
I'm curious about you
on the training side,
what do you all focus on in that training?
And are there things that
y'all do in that training
that you wish were part of,
kind of the mainstream schools of ed?
What would you do if you
could wave a magic wand
on what happens in all teacher training
in the US or in the world?
- Well, there's a few things
Sal that we've learned
over time that just really matter.
And so one of the first
things that's so relevant
to this moment is the
power of relationships.
And I don't know how that rings to you
as you hear that, but it's been really
that is so critical in this very moment.
Our stats are showing or the
stats that folks are sharing
is that we have about 3 million kids
that haven't engaged in
learning over, since March,
either they don't have devices,
so about 17 million do not
have connectivity or devices,
which is, something we just
deeply need to take on.
But we know that the only way
to engage kids and families
into learning is relationships.
And so that's a big
component of just like,
what does it mean
to be able to build the trust.
And I believe change only
happens as fast as there is trust
and deep relationships.
And so that is a component of what we do.
We of course also focus
on, rigorous content.
And we were able to ensure
that all of our core members
got some training on
the science of reading.
And we know that this is just so critical.
I think every teacher at
school needs to ensure
that all teachers get access to this.
We do, training around
computational thinking,
as we think about 21st
century, preparedness.
And the fact that 65%
of kids in grade school
today are gonna seek out jobs
that we don't even know what
they are today is so critical.
And so how are we developing
this critical thinking skills
and the social emotional
skills that are needed.
We also teach in a trauma informed way.
And so that's core to the training
that we are able to provide to
our teachers and the support.
And especially in this
moment when our kids are
in the middle of experiencing
severe loss, fear
and so much uncertainty,
we've gotta ensure that we're really able
to meet the basic needs
for kids, the human needs
and then be able to support them so that,
academically we're not leaving
an entire generation behind,
which is what so many
people are talking about.
And that's still a choice to be made.
Then of course, we have an entire focus
on racial equity and
ensuring that our teachers
are culturally competent teachers
and able to support our kids
in a way that's most responsible,
that leads to the most learning
and engagement overall.
- No, that makes a ton of sense.
We're having questions
come in on social media
from Facebook Livi Valanzuela asks,
"Do you believe children will be behind
"once we returned to
actual physical school?
"What can I do as a parent?"
- You know what, I know
you're familiar Sal
with all the studies coming out
from NWA McKinsey.
So many folks who are
analyzing the situation
and the truth of the matter is that
without question kids on average
are going to be behind and
especially children growing up
in low-income communities
who are disproportionally kids of color,
who are already likely behind on average
coming into schools.
The fact that, as I said earlier,
17 million kids still don't
have access to devices
and connectivity.
And that's only a part of it.
As I know you have Sal
that like technology for
technology sake is not the point.
Once you even then have the technology,
we then have to ensure that we are,
developing our teachers on
how to then teach with this
and ensure that that is in place.
So our kids are able to engage.
And so I do believe that,
every indicator is
telling us that our kids
are gonna be grossly behind.
And so the things I think
we've gotta be focused on
as number one,
ensuring that everyone
truly does have access
to a device and connectivity,
because this isn't about this pandemic.
This is about the future.
This is just a tool that every kid needs.
It is the basics like paper and pencils.
We start about, everyone needs a backpack,
a paper to start school.
Everyone needs access to
a device and connectivity
moving forward for us to
continue to find the path,
to best educate all kids.
And we've gotta train
our teachers on that.
Also, we've got to ensure that we have
information about what our kids need.
There's a lot of questions
right now about testing,
and should we be testing our kids or not?
And it's often tied to accountability.
And this is a moment to,
reimagine how we think about testing
and accountability for this year.
What I feel strongly about
as imperfect as tests are,
we really need to know where are our kids
so that we can appropriately intervene
so that we can be smart
about our investments
in ensuring that kids
get what they need.
And then the last thing I'll say is
we need to make sure
that we are advocating
for dollars for funding during
the last great recession.
We invested a lot more than
we have in this moment,
through this crisis, right now,
we have seen five times less funding
coming into schools
with a much greater challenge
with many complexities.
So not only do we need to
meet the basic needs of kids, right?
I want you educators in schools
right out of, after the pandemic
figure out how are we gonna feed our kids?
We thought, we were
realizing schools feed kids,
schools provide all these
social nets for kids
that suddenly are gone, safety,
access to a clinic, et cetera.
And so right away, our educators
have been focused on meeting those needs.
And we're gonna have
to continue to do that.
And the trauma informed
teaching, but also,
the academics and be smart about that
and ensure that it's personalized.
And that we're really
ensuring that parents
and their families and kids
and teachers, educators are
be able to work together
to figure out how to close those gaps.
So, as a parent, I would
just be asking questions
about how do we know where our kids are
and where investments need to go.
And do have the investments needed
to ensure that we're
able to educate all kids
and invest in our
greatest natural resource
we have in this country,
which is our students.
- Absolutely and just to add
Livi to Elisa's response,
which I 100%agree with,
above and beyond everything
that the schools are doing.
You ask what you can do as a parent,
my advice there is, I don't
know how old your children are,
but to Elisa's point,
there's ways that you
evaluate where your kids are.
You can go to Khan Academy,
especially in math and
science and other areas,
but you can use what we call
our, get ready for grade level courses.
They have something called
a course challenge in it.
And let's say you have a child who's,
I'm making it up, entering sixth grade,
or just entered sixth
grade a few months ago.
You can do the get ready for sixth grade
course challenge.
If they score 80, 90% on it,
that means they don't
have any significant gaps
from pre sixth grade.
And then I would recommend them working
at their own time and pace
20 to 40 minutes a day
in math and personalized practice
going through and trying to get mastery
in all of sixth grade on Khan Academy.
And if they are having trouble
in the get ready for sixth grade,
they can go and look at the units,
or you can work with
them to look at the units
where they have trouble
and then they should get
mastering those gaps.
And then they can go onto
the sixth grade work.
I feel confident if they do that
20, 30, 40 minutes a day
over the course of the
school year and beyond
they're gonna do just fine.
They might even accelerate the learning,
on the English Language Arts side
there's tools, Khan Academy.
You can use, there's four pay tools
that are pretty good, too.
Like Lexia, Raz-Kids.
Once again, you can do
20, 30 minutes a day,
but it can often be as simple as
asking them to read a magazine article,
depending on their age,
read it and then we'll
discuss it at lunch.
If you create those kinds of habits
over the course of the year,
and then the writing,
just make sure they
don't atrophy that skill
say, hey, once a week,
I want you to write
something that you want to change at home.
Change your bedtime,
something you wanna change in the world.
We'll discuss it.
That's make sure they don't atrophy.
But those are just some
things you can make sure
that if your kids do fine
just in your household,
I have no doubt that they're
not going to fall behind.
It's still gonna be suboptimal,
but they won't fall behind.
- Yes, yes, great advice.
- There's a question here
from Facebook, Laura Jones,
"Even students who are
"straight A honors students are failing.
"How do we help them recover from this?
"Even with devices, kids are struggling."
And Elisa I'll add to that question.
What are y'all telling your.
What are your teachers seeing?
And what are you telling them for this?
There's a teacher who
lives in my cul-de-sac,
who has, I live in a middle-class,
upper middle-class neighborhood
where she also is seeing
five, 10% of her kids
are completely disengaged right now.
How are y'all coaching the teaching core
to re-engage or keep these kids engaged
and prevent the situation that Laura
is talking about of a
former straight A student
now failing classes?
- Yeah, this is such an
important question Sal.
And there's a few things
that come to mind.
One is that we haven't hit on yet
is I observed that a lot of our,
the way we're trying to
approach virtual teaching
is the way we approached, being in school,
which really is not working for kids.
There's just enough data and
information that we have.
And if we should just go talk to our kids,
parents talk to their kids
every day and you often hear
it's boring.
I don't understand the point of it.
It just feels so irrelevant
and not pressing.
And so this is an opportunity and at TFA.
We talk about the need for
radical re-imagination.
This is a time for creativity.
This is time to say that isn't working,
what is relevant to our kids?
It's the work kids should be doing
to be in context
of what's happening in
the world right now,
there's so much happening
in the world right now,
that's helping to build their own,
their knowledge and skills.
I read something on the 74 million
and they're doing these letters,
student letters to adults
saying, hello, here's
what we need and want.
And examples, like get kids to,
in your economics class to
actually go figure out
how are you gonna save the business
that doesn't have the,
because of COVID and the
shutdown of the economy
is deeply struggling.
What are the solutions
and what would you do?
And what would you tell
the mayor or the governor?
And just like real-world context
that we can actually really grab onto
and figure out how do we start
ensuring that there's relevance,
that one size fits all,
doesn't work anymore for,
to meet our kids where they are.
And I don't think that
they're gonna show up
unless they can see that this matters
and is interesting
and that they're actually
getting something for it.
The other thing that we observed going on,
as we talk to our own teachers
is our kids have a lot going on.
Our kids now are supporting
their own families.
They've watched, their families lose jobs.
And so, I observed some systems saying,
you gotta show up for these hours
and here's the expectation,
but it's not in the context
of a global pandemic
and the impacts of what
that is having on our kids,
their families and their lives.
And so we've just gotta
be more in conversation
and in relationship
with again families and
the students themselves
to really understand their circumstances,
to then be able to figure out,
how do we adapt?
I'm watching some of our school leaders
get really present with that and
say we can't expect kids
to be in school all day.
They're not gonna do it.
They actually have to go
work to support their family.
And so instead, we're gonna
have these hours in the evening
that seemed to work better six to nine,
or when this is when we're
gonna actually host classes.
And so just the need to really figure out
how do we meet people where
they are in this moment.
And that's what I'm observing
of our network as well.
There's this one school in St. Louis
led by TFA alums, Kairos Academy.
And they had the technology already.
Their whole method was,
it's your round school.
They do leased learning
chunks in seven weeks.
And so they have the technology
'cause they're big on
personalized learning,
but they know that's just one tool.
The thing they also have
is the relationships
and the deep understanding
of how important that is
to be able to execute.
And so they were able to,
through this pandemic,
they have pods,
there's one adult to 10 kids
who are in relationship,
understanding the needs.
And that person also is
liaison to the families.
And so there's a constant,
adapting and ensuring that there's like,
real understanding in order to ensure that
we're able to keep kids engaged
and their engagement
rate is through the roof.
And so it takes us really
thinking about the work
differently and understanding,
and being empathetic to
what are our kids' needs
and really present to that.
- Absolutely and the only
thing I would add to that
is depending on the age of the student,
if you're talking about
someone pre high school,
grades matter in that they're a signal
and that you don't
wanna fail a whole grade
and have to repeat it.
But the important thing is,
is that the child keeps
mastering the concepts.
And as we mentioned,
there's tools to do that,
to make sure they keep mastering.
In high school, when the
stakes are a little bit higher
in terms of your transcript
and college admissions,
I would have a conversation.
Definitely talk to the
child, talk to the student,
but also talk to the school about it.
Because I think right now you're seeing
people are being,
they understand that this
is a very weird situation
and there should be more outlets for kids
who maybe are failing
or having struggling to eventually be able
to get back on the horse
and show that they know the material.
But yeah, it's a real issue.
Let's see, one more.
We have time for one more question.
This time goes by fast
and we're having fun so.
From YouTube, SmartBear,
"How do we help students re-enter school?
"Before they were happy to enter schools
"because they had friends
and there was no virus,
"but now students will be
filled with fear to enter school
"because of the pandemic."
Well, I guess it could be,
I think most people aren't thinking
about seriously re-entering schools
until at earliest the spring,
maybe next school year.
But I think even then
the question is relevant.
People might not be
afraid of the virus then,
but friendships might've been broken,
all sorts of learning gaps.
They're not even used to
the pattern of waking up
and getting ready and
getting on the school bus.
How do you think that's gonna play out?
What should we do?
- Well, so this is where I go back to,
like my hope is that we don't just say
everyone should go back to school
and be doing school in
the same way, right?
Because there are a segment of kids
who are thriving in this environment
who actually don't like
the social and get intimidated
and are able to just sort of clear the air
and really thrive in this environment.
And my question is why can't
that continue to be true
and also figure out how
we can be doing schools
and getting kids back with each other.
We do have enough
research that shows that,
the social development part
of this is really important,
especially for the younger
kids and being back at school.
My kids have been, my four sons
and they've been back in school now
for nearly 11 weeks.
And they love going to school
and they go to a Montessori school
and they have really loved the opportunity
to go back, it's smaller schools,
it's smaller class sizes.
And they're able to,
it's been interesting
to watch my kids thrive
in the environment.
That's a bit different
than what it was before,
but I think we just have to
really be in communication
with our kids and hopefully
thinking creatively
of how do we do school now
that it got interrupted?
What did work about that for,
some kids, what didn't work about that
and how do we really listen to students
and families and communities?
I think solutions are
within the community.
And we often don't spend enough time
really understanding that
to then inform our approach,
which I just think is so key
to being able to do this well.
- Yeah, well, no, well,
there's so much we could
continue to talk about Elisa
As I said, Teach For America
is I think one of the not-for-profits
that I always cite,
honestly, one of the reasons
why I even thought Khan Academy
could be a not-for-profit.
I was like, well, look
here's the not-for-profit
that is in education.
They've been able to scale able
able to have incredible impact.
And so I've always looked up
to the work that y'all do.
And I think what we're
doing is very complimentary
in terms of, y'all are working on
kind of the human capital.
That really is so key in reaching students
and the leadership,
and we're working on the
tools and the content
to help support both that those teachers
and the kids they serve and the family.
So it's been a pleasure to chat with you,
and I hope we can keep
this conversation going
on future days,
both on a live stream and not.
- Yes, you got it.
Thank you so much Sal.
Be well happy holidays.
- You too happy holidays.
Well, thanks everyone for joining.
Thanks for joining today's
session of live stream.
Hopefully you'll be able
to join us tomorrow.
We're going to have Dr. Jharett Bryantt,
assistant superintendent of
Houston Independent School District
and what we're learning
about post-secondary success.
So once kids get to
college and whatever else,
so I will see you then,
and until then have a
good evening or morning
or wherever you are in the world.
I'll hopefully see you tomorrow.